Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
I apologize for my voice today, I am trapped
in this frail human body, and sometimes it
falters.
But, the papers must go on.
This is one of those papers where I find that
more time I spend with it, the more I realize
how amazing it is.
It starts out with an interesting little value
proposition that in and of itself, would likely
not make it to a paper.
So, what is this paper about?
Well, as you see here, this one is about cubification
of 3D geometry.
In other words, we take an input shape, and
it stylizes it to look more like a cube.
Okay, that’s cute, especially given that
there are many-many ways to do this, and it’s
hard to immediately put into words what a
good end result would be, you can see a comparison
to previous works here.
These previous works did not seem to preserve
a lot of fine details, but if you look at
this new one, you see that this one does that
really well.
Very nice indeed.
But still…when I read this paper, at this
point, I was thinking…I’d like a little
more.
Well, I quickly found out that this work has
more up its sleeve.
So much more.
Let’s talk about 7 of these amazing features.
For instance, one, we can control the strength
of the transformation with this lambda parameter,
as you see, the more we increase it, the more
heavy-handed the smushing process is going
to get.
Please remember this part.
Two, we can also cubify selectively along
different directions, or, select parts of
the object that should be cubified differently.
Hmm.
Okay.
Three, we can even use it to fix flaws in
the input 3D geometry.
Four, this transformation procedure also takes
into consideration the orientations - this
means that we can perform it from different
angles, which gives us a large selection of
possible outputs for the same model.
Five, it is fast and works on high-resolution
geometry, and you see different settings for
the lambda parameter here that is the same
parameter as we have talked about before - the
strength of the transformation.
Six, we can also combine many of these features
interactively until a desirable shape is found.
Seven is about to come in a moment, but to
appreciate what that is, we have to look at
…this.
To perform what you have seen here so far,
we have to minimize this expression.
This first term says ARAP, as rigid as possible,
which stipulates that whatever we do in terms
of smushing, it should preserve the fine local
features.
The second part is called a regularization
term that encourages sparser, more axis-aligned
solutions so we don’t destroy the entire
model during this process.
The stronger this term is, the bigger say
it has in the final results, which, in return,
become more cube-like.
So, how do we do that?
Well, of course, with our trusty little lambda
parameter.
Not only that, but if we look at the appendix,
it tells us that we can generalize this second
regularization term for many different shapes.
So here we are, finally, seven, it doesn’t
even need to be cubification, we can specify
all kinds of polyhedra.
Look at those gorgeous results.
I love this paper.
It is playful, it is elegant, it has utility,
and, it generalizes well.
It doesn’t care in the slightest what the
current mainstream ideas are and invites us
into its own little world.
In summary, this will serve all your cubification
needs, and turns out, it might even fix your
geometry, and more.
I would love to see more papers like this.
In this series, I try to make people feel
how I feel when I read these papers.
I hope I have managed this time, but you be
the judge.
Let me know
in the comments.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!